[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
yeah why can't we just keep doing what
we're doing here
no because i think that'll be way more
because it wouldn't be tiger belly if i
didn't
you know what i mean maybe weird make a
little weird but um
i'm just going to tell you how i
discovered you
i you know i i do my whole career to you
yeah
i was i was struggling until no
obviously not covered
not discover you in terms of like you
did it on your own obviously
but no in terms of my my awareness of
you
oh can i tell you that story i remember
it was a big day in my career
bobby lee is finally aware of me
am i on bobby lee's radar see this is
what he's going to do this
is when things start to happen i'm not
going to allow this to that reversal i'm
not yeah i'm not going to allow this to
happen
yeah yeah i'm just going to plug away
you know what i mean listen you can talk
to him all you want
i can hear it i i'm sorry i mean
you just never i never never imagined
you
playing with children
i'm glad you didn't the way you just put
it
no but in terms of like it just it
wasn't like you frolicking
you don't look you don't look like
somebody that would frolic frog
or like you know be in a you know just
just in
wheat in wheat you know and running he
always what backyard was this
no i'm just saying you know what this is
he brought it up
he got uncomfortable so he's trying to
make me uncomfortable i'm not trying to
be
uncomfortable i'm just saying i just you
know would never see you
you know me with butterflies and running
through a field but
right but i i was watching you and i you
know it was we it's are you on mushrooms
so i mention it right and they go we got
to go to the doctor i went over there
today
and my my doctor dr kawashiri can i say
his name
you can't well you just did yeah he's a
great guy yeah he's good yeah yeah
he's one of the best don't believe it
okay i'll make a living i'll make louder
yeah maybe
there maybe there's some promotion there
for him oh good yeah maybe
does he specialize in asians i mean
i mean with a last name like that you
know what's weird he could
it he could because i go to my doctor dr
o'hullahan
he specializes in cirrhosis of the liver
bill this is what he said during our
couple's counseling he was like yeah
like if she's
when she's pregnant i'm just gonna take
more road dates and when the baby's born
oh it's just it was a joke
it wasn't a [ __ ] joke in the [ __ ]
couple's house
but if she's pregnant like in the
beginning when you're fine and
everything
you you can yeah you got to stockpile
the money
for the [ __ ] no that's the nuts the
squirrels cook the nuts during the
summer
for the winter no it's a good move and
then the two months after
you know like the the month before yeah
and then the two months after
i'm there you stay in town and then then
you just do quick hits after that
right see there we go and i don't care
if you you know you
get get a [ __ ] night nurse yeah we'd
get a night nurse babe yeah
sell everything in this garage if you
have to
and i you know i i i've never been like
one to go
are you sure about bending over like i'm
like you know me
i'm i i jump in there's a party i'll
jump in
so i bend over take my pants off
obviously right and
what did you do first oh that's
interesting that's interesting oh
yeah that's interesting i think i
[ __ ] thought that was gonna get a
laugh
i thought it was a ridiculous [ __ ]
how's she gonna break it he just goes
oh that's interesting no no i thought
that was an interesting thing
you know because you're gonna answer
this a normal person would have take
taken the pants off first and then bend
over yeah but what you just
said was i did bend over first
and then took my pants off
that's so [ __ ] weird oh my gosh
and i bent over and there was that that
that moment where the doctor goes you
know what i mean oh my god what are you
doing
ah right and i go i know how it works
this is the way i do it
right so i bent over then i like it you
made it weird back
yeah yeah yeah i reversed it took
control of the weirdness i like it
now he's weirded out right and he goes
what are you waiting for big boy
[Laughter]
so he does you know he you first you
hear
a noise like something's coming out of a
tube okay
right you cut right so he has to put the
lube on and whatnot he has the glove on
and then he doesn't um you know he pearl
harbors it
i mean i know he's coward sherry but
instead of intermediate her alarm was
like he was doing it flying around the
island he went
yeah but he told you he was doing it it
wasn't a sneak attack
it was it was no he said hey sit down
next to me because i want a 3-2-1
don't you want a 3-2-1 when it comes to
your [ __ ] someone yelling that out
three i'd rather run band-aid off no not
me
don't you want that oh there's
opposition i will be entering your
[ __ ] in
three yeah yeah two so i can like
lynch or whatever my body does they
usually say gonna be a little cold
because of the cold he said nothing
you're gonna fend over pressure
for a little pressure is a classic
medical and
i bend over pull the pants out and then
bonsai is what i
thumbs up or just any cindy goes
it's just my um index finger right yeah
i go no that was your thumb bro
he thumbed it you're positive i i i i
i don't have reverse you know what i
mean sight reverse sight yeah
i mean i don't have there's no i don't
know if there's cameras in the room but
i think he [ __ ] thumbed it
it hurt or i might have a tight [ __ ]
or he has short fingers
but i never thought i never thought of
the third [ __ ] option yeah
yeah you could have you've got little
hands maybe he's got little hair you
probably gave him a complex you came
home
came home all moody and his girlfriend's
like what's the matter i don't want to
talk about it what's the matter
it happened again what happened
oh i put my index finger in somebody's
[ __ ] and they were convinced it was
my thumb
you don't understand it's a man thing
okay yeah yeah
baby i might have [ __ ] his day up
i feel like i'm getting cross-examined
yeah thing about him is
that he he has a ways he's one of those
guys like whitney
is like that too where she sees you know
me behaving in a certain way to garner
some sort of sympath
sympathy or you know i'm doing something
psychological
right so that i can get something out of
something and he sees through it where
other people
they fall into it and they go oh no you
know and they you know i mean
i've just been around a lot of dirt bags
so i
yeah but you can't you're gonna need a
colonoscopy you're almost 50. did you do
one
yeah it's the easiest thing ever yeah
like okay this is gonna smell like
peppermint and then five seconds later
it's like all right your ass is great
no problems that's literally what it
feels like yeah but what sucks is the
day
of the day before the stuff you have to
drink is a little bit
gross but when you're weighing that
versus dying to ask cancer
it's just like uh yeah i'll definitely
i'll choose this yeah yeah
here's here's the deal the honest truth
is this
i just love that whole body like okay
here's here's the deal here
let's get ready let's get real so um you
know i'm almost 50
and i feel like um things are kind of
slowly happening for me as well right
it's just nice to see like you know what
you've been on [ __ ] television for
like almost 30 years
what are you talking about mad tv oh my
god and everything
okay first of all mad tv was like doing
community theater
that's how much we got paid i'm not well
did you get [ __ ] over in show business
did you think there was a big pot of
gold and somebody else took it from you
yeah that's what happens but you were
still on tv you still walk down the
street and people like oh my god it's
bobby lee
from mad tv okay fine fine you're right
and i'm grateful
okay but i'm just saying that empathy
that i have for you right now is just
awesome
how much of your day is trying to pick
this up
[Laughter]
and keep it yeah buoyant
why don't comics why do comics not like
compliments
i know i think some of them do look i i
respect
you know other comics liking what i do i
do enjoy that [ __ ] but i don't want to
sit here
and and just like listen to that
you're giving him the worst experience i
just want to like hang out and take
whoever's watching this
laugh you don't have to go james lipton
like what like like paint like do you do
pottery stuff and paint oh i'm
beyonce like what do you do i can
i can do her hair i can like i can do
i can french braid i can do the whole i
can get her because i had this
this horrible feeling that one day my
wife wasn't gonna be there
and she was gonna have to go to school
with their hair not looking the way she
wanted and i remember going to school
every day with orange hair what the [ __ ]
that was like so i remember that so i
was just like i'm gonna make sure
that that you you you're looking all
right now i'm like totally [ __ ] into
it's crazy
yeah cause now like i see [ __ ] and like
women like
in movies and stuff and i'm looking at
their hair trying to figure out how to
do it
yeah yeah i bet you you do this i don't
know
i'm not at your house but um do you
watch programs with her
like like entertainment that's the best
thing is uh
i got she's into bugs bunny oh wow
classics yeah
but you gotta watch out cause there is
some old school bugs bunny they got a
little bit of blackface in there
and they got a little bit of uh we we we
were
we were you know at war with uh donald
duck that's not a block with japan
so there's some there's some war
propaganda it's kind of funny when they
do it to the germans because it's white
on white but the other way it gets a
little crazy but
if you stay with the mainstream ones
yeah it's fine and what's what's
awesome is uh we got we got an argument
about bugs bunny is she's convinced that
elmer fudd's name is doc
because he says what's up doc and i'm
like no that's just what he says his
name's elmer fudd she's going no
his name is doc i was going like no it's
elmer fudd
and she got really upset and so i just
all right it's dark it's dark
[Music]
[Music]
just the wrong way